quand lakovic 19 a frappé l'hiver
dernier certains travailleurs étaient en
première ligne
ils nous ont soignés nourris protéger il
était aux anges gardiens beaucoup
d'entre eux venaient du même
arrondissement à montréal un secteur qui
a été particulièrement affectés par la
pandémie
nous sommes le 9 septembre dernier dans
une arrière-cour ducati montréal nord
une douzaine de résidents sont réunis
pour partager leur expérience de la
pandémie selon le même thème se
développe une et en santé la deuxième
vague n'a pas encore frappé
merci mais déjà on la redoute
[Musique]
durant la première vague montréal nord a
été touché par la coved 19 plus que
n'importe quel autre quartier au canada
effectivement mauvais la nord qui semble
être le seul quartier qui a plus de 3000
cas de co vide par cent mille habitants
l'anthropologue isabelle avec connaît
bien montréal-nord depuis sept ans elle
mène des recherches sur le terrain pour
parole d'exclues un obnl qui lutte
contre la pauvreté l'exclusion sociale
dans le quartier quand la coved 19
commence à se propager au mois de mars
2020 elle redoute le pays
montréal nord un taux assez élevé de
travailleurs essentiel donc qui sont
dans le domaine de la santé et des
préposés aux bénéficiaires
beaucoup de personnes aussi qui
travaillent en alimentation donc ce sont
des types d'emplois où les gens ne
peuvent pas faire du télétravail où il
continuait à être en contact avec la
population où il continue à se déplacer
dans le quartier les familles nombreuses
sont souvent à l'étroit dans de petits
logements
c'est plus difficile de s'isoler
lorsqu'on a la queue vide donc ça
augmente la transmission communautaire
et de façon générale la densité du
quartier le fait qu'il ya moins
d'espacés verts que dans d'autres
quartiers
ça aussi ça rend le confinement plus
difficiles partout dans le monde
des études ont montré que les quartiers
défavorisés sont plus touché par la
pandémie
[Musique]
les minorités ethniques sont aussi
surreprésentés dans les cas de kobe 19
[Musique]
estelle card travail sur les inégalités
sociales de santé depuis 20 ans ces
recherches montrent comment les
populations au bas de l'échelle sociale
ou victimes de racisme sont plus à
risque de contracter des maladies et
d'être moins bien soignés ou comme ça
que la pauvreté matérielle n'explique
pas tout les minorités raciales après
ajustement sur le niveau socio
économiques restent plus affectés par la
pandémie
aux etats unis les noirs sont trois fois
plus à risque d'attraper le virus que
les blancs selon des chiffres rapportés
par les centres américains de contrôle
et de prévention des maladies
ils sont deux fois plus susceptibles
d'en mourir à toronto durant la première
vague 83% des personnes atteintes de
lakovic 19 faisait partie des minorités
ethniques en france on a vu ça par
exemple dans les départements de seine
saint denis en banlieue parisienne sont
sur représentés en fait les immigrants
par rapport au reste de la france des
immigrants qui sont racisées donc les
minorités visibles et bien c'est là
effectivement que la pandémie a frappé
le plus fort
québec contrairement à d'autres régions
du monde on ne collecte pas de données
sur l'origine ethnique des personnes
atteintes de lakovic 19
c'est une erreur selon snk si on ne
recueille pas ces données là mais on
peut pas les mettre en évidence donc on
peut pas les comprendre et on parle
lutter conte la sociologue craint que la
pandémie d'aujourd'hui ne creusent les
inégalités du futur elles redoutent
particulièrement les conséquences de la
fermeture des écoles durant la première
vague au québec
indirectement la pandémie creuse des
inégalités entre les différents enfants
d'aujourd'hui qui sont des adultes de
demain parce que les enfants issus des
milieux socio-économiques plus
défavorisés vont prendre plus de retard
par rapport aux autres parce que moi des
espaces tranquilles pour travailler pour
se concentrer moins d'accompagnement
virtuellement par les parents aussi
parle-moi bien français s'ils ont plus
de difficultés à suivre même la
scolarité
isabelle est là constaté dans le
quartier montréal-nord les ménages à
faible revenu ont moins accès à une
connexion ethernet et aux équipements
nécessaires pour se brancher
on à en discuter avec beaucoup de
familles avec beaucoup d'enfants la
maison qu'ils avaient accès à un
ordinateur ou à un téléphone donc on
comprend que c'est extrêmement difficile
de faire ses devoirs de suivre les
rencontres et ims dans ces circonstances
là
[Musique]
pour tenter de réduire les inégalités
parole d'exclues a lancé le projet
espace santé citoyens on organise des
ateliers qui vise entre autres à aider
les résidents de montréal nord à mieux
naviguer dans le système de santé
pour avoir plus facilement accès aux
soins dans le quartier n'y a pas de
clinique qui sont de proximité
l'infirmier dany et ses triplettes
travail comme bénévole pour parole
d'exclues ces exemptions à avoir accès à
une clinique puis elle est pas
nécessairement proche physiquement il
faut que tu prennes autobus mais ça te
demande de payer des frais pour
l'autobus
par la suite c'est est en mesure d'aller
dans un endroit que tu sens qui est
accueillant que tu te sens pas
marginalisés ou comme discriminer deux
par kid suez est ainsi que dans le grand
désarroi que oui on apporte nos savoirs
eux aussi apporté savoir ils sont les
experts du vécu il est extrêmement
important de tenir compte de ces savoirs
là pour développer des programmes des
solutions pour réduire ces inégalités
isabelle est constate que ce sont avant
tout les résidents qui ont sauvé le
quartier montréal-nord
durant la première vague de la pandémie
la communauté s'est mobilisée en
distribuant de la nourriture aux
familles dans le besoin
des masques ont diffusant des messages
de prévention
contrairement à estelle card crise à
belek redoutent la collecte
d'informations sur l'origine ethnique
des malades de lakovic 19
moi je dirais qu'on ne devrait collecter
les données si il ya des actions qui
suivent
l'intérêt des statistiques c'est
d'orienter les politiques publiques donc
c'est extrêmement important que il ya
une réponse gouvernementale qui suit
sinon ça peut être un fardeau lourd à
porter et c'est le cas pour montréal
nord